C'est très intéressant de voir quand il s'agit des narratives de Jésus, des événements
où Jésus l'a vécu, c'est très intéressant d'essayer de nous mettre à la place de quelques
personnages pour pouvoir avoir plus de sensibilité aux choses qui se passent là-dedans.
Et notamment, je pense qu'à ces moments-là, il faut qu'on soit à la place de l'aveugle.
C'est vraiment ça qu'on va voir l'enseignement de Jésus au travers de ces passages.
Et donc, à la place de l'aveugle, je voulais vraiment vous inviter à essayer d'imaginer
cette situation, cette circonstance.
Donc, on pourrait faire ça de plusieurs manières, juste défier les yeux.
Mais même là, je considère qu'on ne peut pas comprendre quelle est la situation ou l'incapacité
d'un aveugle si on n'est pas né comme un aveugle.
Mais essayer d'imaginer, d'avoir la privation de la vision, de ne pouvoir pas voir les choses.
Et c'est à partir de là qu'on commence à comprendre aussi les privilèges qu'on a
de pouvoir voir les choses, regarder les choses.
Il y a une dimension de plaisir énorme et incroyable au travers des choses qu'on voit
avec nos yeux.
Et je pense, une manière pour moi de méditer, de mettre la place de cet aveugle-là, c'était
vraiment de me rappeler la première fois où j'ai vu un certain nombre de choses dans
ma vie.
Donc, par exemple, moi j'étais élégé à Rio, au Brésil.
Et c'était pour moi toujours un plaisir de pouvoir regarder la beauté de la nature,
de regarder les montagnes de la mer, etc.
Et c'était presque une habitude pour moi.
Et des fois je ne prenais pas tous les plaisirs que je pourrais prendre en regardant toutes
ces choses-là.
Mais la première fois quand je suis venu en France, je suis allé à la neige.
Et c'était incroyable pour moi de regarder la neige.
C'était la première fois où j'ai vu cette beauté dans la création de Dieu.
Et c'était une expérience, je dirais spirituelle même dans un sens.
Car c'était la première fois où j'ai vu une telle beauté.
Et je pense que ça peut être la même chose la première fois où j'ai vu ma fille, ma
première fille naître.
Et la même chose pour la deuxième.
Et c'est très intéressant quand on voit la première fois qu'on voit des choses
qu'on n'a pas vues encore et qu'on voulait regarder.
C'est une expérience énorme et incroyable.
Quand on pense de cette manière, on peut s'approcher un peu de cette notion d'être
aveugle et les privilèges de voir.
Mais quand on considère ce que le texte est en train de nous montrer, c'est la possibilité
de regarder à Dieu.
Donc même si on est là tout le temps en train de considérer qu'est-ce que je voulais
voir dans ma vie que je n'ai pas encore vu, on pourrait penser à plusieurs paysages
différents.
On pourrait penser aux choses qu'on pense que les jours où on peut avoir ces choses,
on sera plus heureux.
Mais le très intéressant dans ces passages, c'est que Dieu est en train de nous inviter
à méditer dans la possibilité de voir à Dieu le même.
Et ça c'est une aspiration, même si on n'est pas conscient de ça, c'est une aspiration
la plus profonde, la plus basique dans le cœur de tous les êtres humains.
car peu importe ce qu'on désire de voir dans nos vies, on est toujours en train, comme
dirait Augustin, on est en train de vouloir voir à Dieu sans s'apercevoir.
On est en train de chercher, de voir les choses que Dieu a créées et on espère que ces
choses-là, les jours où on va les voir, ces choses vont remplir nos cœurs complètement.
humains. Mais la vérité c'est que pendant l'histoire, soit au travers les voies de la
religion, la plus grande aspiration des êtres humains, c'est de connaître, d'avoir un
contact avec les sumo bonnes, d'avoir un contact avec Dieu lui-même, l'origine.
Donc cette aspiration, la possibilité de voir à Dieu, c'était une aspiration incroyable.
Et la parole de Dieu, elle nous dit très clairement, ou une petite touche de la partie de Dieu.
Je vais juste vous mentionner une personne, c'est Moïse. Et Moïse c'est tellement incroyable,
lui il a demandé à Dieu qu'il puisse les voir, qu'il puisse voir sa gloire.
Ça veut dire, qu'est-ce que les hommes voient quand ils voient Dieu.
Et la description biblique c'est toujours étonnant, c'est la majesté, c'est la gloire,
il faut cacher les yeux. C'est une beauté tellement énorme, c'est une majesté tellement
indescriptible, que quand on est en train de contempler Dieu, on est en train de contempler
la satisfaction de toutes nos attentes en même temps. Peu importe le type de plaisir qu'on
puisse imaginer, c'est la possibilité de regarder celui qui habite dans une lumière
que personne ne peut accéder. Voilà la description biblique de la place où Dieu
il habite. Si vous vous rappelez bien, la vision de Jérémie, de trône de Dieu, qu'est-ce
qu'il voit ? Il voit des anges, des chérubins. Et quelle est la caractéristique de ces chérubins ?
Ils avaient trois paires d'ailes, et pour moi la plus crueuse, ce sont les ailes qui sont
dans leur face, dans leur visage. Il faut qu'ils cachent leur visage d'une vision directe
de la présence de Dieu, à cause de la majesté, de l'éclat de la gloire de Dieu.
Si on se rappelle bien, quel est le plus grand ange qui a été jamais créé ? C'était
Lucifer, Satan qui après est tombé. Et pourquoi il est appelé, depuis l'origine, avant sa
chute, il est appelé les chérubins de la garde ou un. Qu'est-ce qu'il gardait ? Il avait
le privilège d'accéder à la présence de Dieu avec une proximité que les autres anges
ne pouvaient pas. Et ce qu'il gardait, c'était la présence de Dieu pour que les autres anges
ne voient pas l'éclat de Dieu directement, avant que les péchés rentrent. La beauté
de la sainteté de Dieu, elle est tellement incroyable et tellement énorme que personne
ne peut pas vivre en voyant à Dieu directement. Et ça c'est énorme, c'est étonnant d'imaginer
par exemple une petite illustration de la gloire de Dieu, c'est le soleil qui nous a donné
aussi comme cette illustration. Les personnes n'ont pas la capacité de beaucoup s'approcher
du soleil et continuer à lui regarder. Et quand on considère la gloire de la vie qui
va venir, elle n'a pas besoin du soleil car la gloire de Dieu va tout allumer. Ça c'est
énorme, c'est incroyable l'invitation biblique, la possibilité qu'on puisse voir à Dieu.
Révenant Moïse, c'est que c'est étonnant pour moi, c'est qu'il cache sa face, il regarde
la montagne, il tourne son dos vers Dieu et la Bible dit de façon métaphorique qu'il
sait qu'il est le dos des dieux qui Dieu permet qu'Abraham les voit. Et quand on voit
c'est les reflets des dos des dieux dans les murs qui viennent vers la face de Moïse.
On peut parler d'une triple réflexion qui s'est passé à ce moment-là. Et quand on
voit Moïse qui sort de cette montagne quand il descend, sa face elle brille car il a pu
toucher légèrement la gloire de Dieu. Et les personnes n'arrivent pas à regarder
lui directement dans sa face à cause de la gloire de Dieu, à cause du fait qu'il avait
vu une petite expression de la gloire de Dieu. Voilà, nous sommes devant cette discussion.
Et l'abîme nous dit que personne ne peut regarder à Dieu. Il y a un besoin, comment je peux dire,
un besoin déterminant qui s'en puisse voir Dieu, il faut qu'il se révèle, il faut qu'il
se dévoile. C'est pour ça que l'abîme nous dit qu'il parle à sa sagesse humaine,
personne n'a jamais que nous à Dieu. Mais Dieu, il s'est dévoilé. Comme Brouille nous
dit, au début Dieu s'est dévoilé au travers de ses prophètes qui sont en train de décrire
leurs expériences avec Dieu au travers de sa parole. Mais dernièrement, Dieu, il nous a
parlé au travers de son fils. Et son fils c'est quoi? C'est l'expression parfaite
des lettres de Dieu. Personne n'a jamais un vu à Dieu, mais Jésus-Christ, Dieu lui-même,
il est venu pour nous enseigner, pour nous afficher. Si nous voulons voir à Dieu, on a besoin qu'il
se dévoile. Il faut qu'on soit en train de nous approcher de Dieu avec cet espoir. Pourquoi
on ne peut pas voir à Dieu? Déjà, car lui, il est le créateur, il est l'essent, ça veut
dire, il est très élevé, mais aussi car nous avons aujourd'hui un cœur impur. Et
ça veut dire, à cause de notre impureté de cœur, nous sommes comme des morts spirituels.
Et dans ce domaine-là, il faut qu'on considère, nous ne sommes pas du tout loin de la condition
de cet aveugle. Notre incapacité de regarder à Dieu est telle que Jésus est en train d'illustrer
à partir d'un aveugle. C'est impossible pour un aveugle de regarder les choses. Il faut
que Dieu, non seulement se dévoile, on est en train de considérer la possibilité, même
en train de voir le Christ, les pharisiens n'arrivent pas à vraiment le voir, et même
les disciples qui sont dans la compagnie directe de Christ, il y a la possibilité que Dieu soit
en train de se dévoiler, et même là, les personnes de lui ne regardent pas. Ça veut
dire, il faut que Dieu, non seulement se révèle à nous, mais qu'il touche nos vies d'une
telle façon, à point de nous guérir de notre cécité spirituelle. Et c'est ça la thématique
de ce texte. Ce texte, il est en train de nous poser cette question. Comment on peut arriver
à voir le Christ? Comment on peut arriver à regarder le Christ clairement? Et voilà,
on sait bien que toujours quand on est devant des miracles, il y a deux choses qui se passent.
Les miracles, en soi-même, il sert à nous pointer envers le Christ, ok? Donc c'est pour
ça que Jésus est en train de faire des signes. On sait que son ministère principal, c'est
prêcher la parole, c'est parler de la Bonne Nouvelle, et il utilise les miracles pour
rendre clair le fait qu'il est Dieu lui-même, qu'il est le Fils de Dieu. Mais plus que
ça, les miracles, il a toujours une connotation spirituelle, il a une illustration des choses
spirituelles. Et plus que ça, dans ces textes, ça c'est très intéressant, pourquoi Marc,
il a choisi de mettre cet enregistrement de ces miracles vraiment au milieu du chapitre
8. La thématique du chapitre 8, c'est vraiment Jésus qui est étonné avec un environnement
religieux présent dans la vie des personnes. Et même avec cet environnement religieux,
les personnes n'arrivent pas à voir les Christs. Les disciples sont très lents à pouvoir avoir
une vision claire de Christ. Ça veut dire, c'est toujours la discussion autour de l'aveuglement
spirituel. Et là, c'est le premier miracle qu'on voit, que Jésus fait jusqu'à là, où il ne fait pas
une guérison automatique. Vous avez vu là? Donc il fait une double touche. C'est la première fois où Dieu
ne guérit pas en personne immédiatement ou complètement. Et ce qui s'est passé avant, et ce qui va se passer
après cet épisode-là, ça montre et ça nous réveille la persistance de la cécité spirituelle dans nos vies.
Donc avant, c'était les disciples qui n'arrivaient pas à voir encore ce qu'on a considéré les dimanches
derniers. Et après, on va voir les Saint-Esprits qui va révéler à Pierre qui vous dites qui je suis.
Pierre va dire que tu es le Christ, fils de Dieu vivant. Et juste après, Jésus va parler des choses
qu'il faut se passer, qu'il va mourir, qu'il va souffrir. Et Pierre n'est pas disposé à voir ces choses-là.
Il est très attaché aux paramètres, les humains, il veut protéger les Christs. Donc il veut accepter la
vérité juste par la moitié, dans un sens. Et c'est pour ça qu'il a empêché de voir clairement les Christs,
car il n'est pas disposé à écouter exclusivement les Christs ou tout ce que les Christs peuvent dire.
Et c'est très intéressant donc pourquoi Marc, il prend cet épisode et le met là au milieu des choses,
car il y a une dimension progressive de notre capacité de voir les Christs. Et des fois, on a besoin de cette
double touche des dieux. On a déjà eu une touche dans notre vie, c'était le moment de notre conversion,
mais il faut qu'on soit touché constamment par les Christs pour qu'on arrive à voir les choses plus claires.
On a déjà vu les dimanches derniers, dans un domaine plutôt naturel, comment on peut essayer de faire des efforts
pour s'aimer un cœur enseignable. Comment on peut faire des efforts pour nous détacher de la culture,
nous détacher des faux prophètes, des faux enseignements. Et aujourd'hui, ce que Jésus est en train de nous montrer,
c'est que, ok, ces choses-là, elles ont son lieu, mais elles ne sont pas suffisantes pour nettoyer vos cœurs vraiment.
Ça veut dire la seule chose qui peut nettoyer notre cœur, qui peut vraiment guérir notre vision spirituelle,
c'est une nouvelle touche des dieux. Et donc, la vérité principale de ce texte, c'est que les Christs,
ça veut dire Dieu lui-même, il n'est pas que les points de départs au travers desquels nous voyons à Dieu,
il est les lentilles perpétuelles au travers desquelles nous verrons à Dieu chaque fois plus claires.
C'est clair pour vous ?
Ça veut dire, c'est pas que d'avoir reçu une touche des dieux quand on était mort spirituellement,
cet homme-là, il reçoit la première touche, il voit les choses, mais il voit encore les hommes comme s'ils étaient des arbres.
C'est flûte encore sa vision, mais c'est déjà quelque chose de remarquable.
Et ensuite, après la deuxième touche, il arrive à voir les choses clairement.
Donc Jésus, il a les débuts, il a la fin, il a les parcours.
Donc il faut qu'on soit toujours disposé à regarder lui directement.
Et donc il y a ces deux aspects dans la vie chrétienne.
Notre capacité de voir Dieu dépend complètement de la touche de Christ.
Et l'aspect progressif, c'est notre capacité de voir Dieu va être chaque fois plus claire
à cause du Christ aussi, du travail continuel de Christ en nous.
Et donc la question qu'on va poser à ce texte, c'est la question très claire là,
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour voir Dieu ?
C'est très simple.
Si vous vous considérez déjà des chrétiens, il y a des implications très pratiques pour vous aussi.
Si vous ne les considérez pas, c'est là le point de départ.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour voir Dieu ?
Donc selon les textes, on va considérer quatre points.
Ils sont très pratiques, ça va être très très objectif.
Donc déjà, la première chose, c'est que pour être guéri de la cécité spirituelle,
il faut reconnaître notre besoin.
Ça veut dire une maladie que personne ne peut guérir.
Est-ce que ça c'est clair pour vous ?
Quand vous regardez en arrière, si vous vous considérez des chrétiens,
est-ce que vous considérez que votre situation au départ, c'était quelque chose que personne ne pourrait guérir ?
Quand on lit les BC 21 et 22, on voit comment se fait si...
Pardon.
BC 22.
« Ils s'est rendu à Bethsaida, en amena un aveugle vers Jésus, et on le souplia de les toucher. »
Donc c'est très clair dans ce texte-là.
Des fois, Jésus est étonné avec la foi d'un païen qui s'approche de lui, d'un non-chrétien qui s'approche de lui.
À cette fois-ci, on ne voit pas une expression très forte de la foi de l'aveugle.
Mais c'était quelqu'un qui avait une compréhension tellement profonde de son incapacité de voir,
qu'il se confiait à d'autres personnes, d'autres amis.
Et sa chance, il était chanceux, car ces amis-là, eux, ils avaient la foi dans les Christs.
Et donc ces hommes, ils prennent son ami, ils les ramènent jusqu'à les Christs,
et là, cet aveugle, il se laisse conduire.
Ce n'est pas étonnant qu'avant notre conversion, je me rappelle très bien,
qu'avant notre conversion, on n'arrive pas à comprendre les choses des dieux.
Je me rappelle, je prenais la Bible, je prenais un dictionnaire à côté,
et j'essayais de comprendre la parole des dieux.
Je pensais que c'était à cause d'un langage ancien.
Mais à la fin, la Bible nous dit que les choses spirituelles se discernent spirituellement.
Si on n'a pas l'aide du Saint-Esprit, on ne va jamais arriver à comprendre.
Les problèmes n'est pas de se dire, moi je suis incapable de comprendre.
Les problèmes, c'est de faire semblant, à cause de l'orgueil,
que les problèmes sont avec la Bible.
Ou que je suis capable de voir les choses.
Ce n'est pas un problème de s'approcher de Jésus en disant,
moi je suis aveugle pour les choses spirituelles.
Je n'arrive pas à comprendre les choses spirituelles.
Je vois votre foi, vous les chrétiens, mais je n'arrive pas à comprendre ces choses-là.
Et donc, la chose la plus sage à faire, c'est de nous confier à ceux qui peuvent nous guérir.
Et donc, ça veut dire, le premier pas pour la guérison, c'est très clair,
c'est la reconnaissance de notre besoin.
Jésus lui-même, il a dit, je ne suis pas venu pour les sangs, je suis venu pour les malades.
Qu'est-ce qu'il voulait dire avec ça?
Je suis venu pour ceux qui reconnaissent vraiment leur cécité spirituelle, leur mort spirituelle.
Et c'est à partir de ces moments où Dieu commence à travailler.
Ceux qui pensent qu'il voit déjà toutes les choses, qui sont toujours en train de juger les Christ,
donc je vais donner juste un exemple.
Il ne faut jamais commencer dans l'évangélisation avec des arguments ou des discussions
pour convaincre une personne que Jésus, il est le seul moyen exclusif, serré, raisonnable, tout ça.
La raison, elle fortifie une foi déjà vivante,
mais elle n'est jamais capable d'opérer la régénération dans la vie des personnes.
Et aujourd'hui, il y a cette notion commune de la philosophie
où toutes les personnes vont dire, tous les chemins apportent à Dieu.
Ça c'est une arrogance encore plus grande.
Pourquoi je suis en train de dire ça?
Car ça peut sembler très humble quand on dit comme ça,
mais quand on considère que c'est la position la plus haute qu'on peut imaginer.
Donc il est là en train de se dire, voilà,
que toutes les religions sont en train de vouloir décrire à Dieu,
mais moi je suis le seul qui peut voir au-delà d'eux en fait.
Ils sont là en train de voir à Dieu de différents côtés, de différentes manières,
mais moi je vois les choses clairement.
Et ce que je vois, c'est que personne ne peut dire, moi c'est le seul chemin.
Donc moi j'ai une connaissance de Dieu beaucoup plus élevée que toutes les religions.
Vous comprenez?
C'est très subtil.
Mais c'est comme ça que les personnes marchent dans leur mentalité aujourd'hui.
Et quelle est notre sortie là-dedans?
Notre sortie là-dedans c'est de faire des efforts pour que les personnes arrivent à comprendre
que nous sommes tous dans la même condition, aveugles et spirituels.
Il y a seulement une manière d'être guéri.
Mais celui qui va guéri ce n'est pas moi, c'est Jésus.
Donc moi je pense que ce sont les premières pas, c'est vraiment de confesser notre condition d'aveuglement.
Et on va exprimer ça avec une humble ouverture pour que les personnes puissent nous parler des dieux.
Et surtout pour que Jésus puisse nous parler des dieux.
La deuxième chose c'est qu'il pourrait guéri de la cécité spirituelle,
il faut se confier complètement au Christ.
Et ça c'est très intéressant.
Donc si moi je reconnais que je n'ai pas la capacité de voir les choses clairement dans un domaine spirituel,
c'est clair que Jésus il est déjà célèbre, il a divisé l'histoire quand même.
Au moins il faut que je fasse confiance aux choses qu'il lui dit.
Parce que toutes les religions, toutes les religions essayent de toucher au Christ de façon d'autre.
Donc moi au moins je vais essayer de lui écouter plus eux,
qui est mes convictions, qui est les choses que j'ai apprises, qui est mes philosophies ou qui est ma culture.
Et donc qu'est-ce qui se passe là à ce moment ?
Cet homme il passe à se confier complètement à Jésus.
Donc Jésus il prend l'aveugle par l'amant,
ça veut dire qu'il prend la passe d'un conducteur pour un aveugle,
il laisse ses amis à côté, vous avez lui apporté jusqu'à là,
à partir de là je suis le vrai conducteur.
Et c'est à moi de lui conduire envers la vérité.
Et voilà que Jésus prend cet homme par la main,
il conduit cet homme à l'extérieur du village,
il mit la salive sur ses yeux,
il posa l'aimant sur lui et il demanda s'il voyait quelque chose.
Ok ?
Donc Jésus, ça c'est très intéressant,
je voulais vraiment appeler votre attention,
il y a un aspect en Dieu qui s'est immuable.
Ça c'est clair ?
C'est mon là pour vous c'est clair ?
Il ne change pas.
Mais la manière de Dieu agir,
elle est imprévisible.
Et c'est étonnant aujourd'hui,
on attend toujours que les personnes passent par une conversion
très pas à pas.
Moi je ne fais pas trop de confiance dans des méthodes,
des stratégies.
Je vois toujours un Jésus qui traite exclusivement
et d'une façon très personnelle avec chaque personne.
et nos vies elles sont irrépétibles.
Donc Jésus il prend cet homme par la main
et il lui guérit,
décide de le guérit de manière complètement différente
de ce qu'il venait en train de faire.
Et en fait, ce sont très peu des moments,
je ne peux pas même me rappeler d'un moment
où Jésus guérit deux personnes de la même manière.
Et donc Jésus il a sa façon de faire les choses.
Donc son caractère ne change pas,
son amour ne change pas,
sa manière de s'approcher des personnes,
ça change beaucoup.
Et sa manière de traiter des personnes,
Et donc c'est très intéressant,
on veut toujours voir que toutes les personnes
passent par les mêmes étapes dans la conversion.
Et là, il faut faire attention.
Donc, de faire confiance complètement au Christ,
c'est de faire confiance dans sa manière de nous guider.
Ok ?
Et il faut garder là cette compréhension.
Il est en train de nous ramener tous dans la même place,
mais de manière différente.
Donc, qu'est-ce qu'il fait ?
Il prend cet homme parlement,
il prend la place du guide.
On a déjà considéré ça.
Avez-vous déjà complètement confié votre vie à Jésus
comme ton guide ?
De lui permettre de te conduire,
n'importe où il veut te conduire.
Ok ?
Donc, c'est ça, c'est de reconnaître ton aveuglité.
Un, c'est livrant complètement à lui.
Après, il donne à cet homme-là
un traitement exclusif et personnel.
Il le fait sortir du village.
Et d'habitude, Dieu fait comme ça.
Donc, il y a des choses-là qu'on voit,
d'habitude, Dieu fait de cette manière,
mais il y a quelque chose, c'est complètement différent.
Donc, d'habitude,
Dieu est en train de nous séparer.
Nous séparer du monde,
dans un premier moment.
Ok ?
De nous séparer pour devenir sa possession,
car il a payé les prix.
Ok ?
On est devenu une race élue,
un sacerdoce royal,
une nation sainte,
un peuple des propriétés exclusives des dieux.
Voilà les langages bibliques.
Donc, ça veut dire,
il est en train de nous faire sortir,
mais de nous faire sortir de la culture,
de notre environnement religieux.
Il va faire ça toujours,
car il y a beaucoup dans la religion
qui viennent des hommes.
Il est en train d'enlever ces hommes-là
et de les rapprocher,
de les rapprocher,
cet homme-là,
et de les rapprocher de lui.
Donc, il est cette génération,
comme on a déjà vu.
Une séparation du village.
Il ne va pas devenir un spectacle
pour tous qui sont là pour regarder.
Ce n'était pas la manière de Christ
de faire les choses.
Et une séparation pour lui.
Pour moi, ça, c'est la plus grande emphase.
Il faut qu'on ait cette expérience personnelle.
La vie chrétienne,
elle est une vie de foi communautaire.
Mais pour arriver à vivre la foi communautaire,
il faut qu'on soit né à nouveau d'abord.
Et pour être né à nouveau d'abord,
il faut qu'on ait cette expérience personnelle
avec le Christ.
avait déjà vécu ça.
De sentir la touche de Jésus en vous.
De sentir qu'il vous a sorti de la vie,
de la culture.
Il a venu vous parler séparément.
Il veut que sa voix soit plus haute
que toutes les autres voix
qu'on est en train de voir.
Les voix des circonstances,
d'écouter.
les voix des avis des personnes
par rapport à la religion
quand on est en train de s'approcher.
Les voix-là qui nous appellent
personnellement,
ils nous parlent directement.
Et donc, il a fait sortir cet homme de l'art.
Il faut évaluer ça.
Et après, il fait un traitement libre.
Ça veut dire,
il utilise cette méthode-là incroyable,
différente.
Et donc, on peut essayer de deviner
pourquoi il a fait de cette manière.
Il y a des commentaristes bibliques
qui vont suggérer des choses.
Pour moi, c'est très intéressant quand même.
Un de ces commentaristes nous dit
qu'il a mis de la salive dans sa main
pour que ça puisse
pour que sa main puisse être plus sensible
quand il touche les yeux de cet homme-là.
Une fois que cet homme-là
n'avait pas la capacité de regarder,
ses autres sens,
ils étaient plus,
comment on peut dire,
plus fortes, plus sensibles.
Et donc, c'était comme si l'écrit,
il était en train de parler la langue
de cet homme-là.
Ça, c'est très intéressant
pour le voir d'application.
Il n'y en a pas l'assurance
que ce soit les cas.
Le fait, c'est que c'était
un moment complètement nouveau,
d'une manière complètement nouvelle.
Et voilà que pour moi,
le plus intéressant,
c'est de considérer le fait
que cet homme,
il s'est confié complètement
au Christ
dans sa manière de faire la chose.
Une chose que je voulais juste vous poser
pour appliquer ces points-là,
c'est vraiment de considérer
si tu as,
si tu fais confiance
à la manière de Dieu guider ta vie.
On est toujours en train de considérer
les circonstances qu'on vit
à partir de nos paramètres,
de ce qui serait le meilleur pour nous.
Et voilà que des fois,
Dieu peut nous amener vers des voies,
en fait,
qu'on n'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi.
Pourquoi il est en train de faire
de cette manière.
mais nos vies,
elles sont tous exclusives
et vécues avec Christ
d'une façon inédite.
Bon,
avant de passer au prochain point,
il y a quelque chose
qui se passe ici,
qui a une implication pour nous
en tant qu'évangélisation.
Qu'est-ce que ces amis
de cet homme,
ils ont fait ?
Donc ça,
c'est pour moi,
c'est un des points
les plus forts de ces textes.
Ces amis,
ils avaient à la fois
un Christ,
ok ?
Ils prennent cet aveugle
et ils ramènent cet aveugle
jusqu'à la présence de Christ.
Et le texte nous dit
qu'ils ont imploré
à Jésus de lui toucher.
Donc,
ils n'avaient pas la capacité
de guérir
cet homme-là.
Cet homme,
il était aveugle,
il n'avait pas la possibilité
de voir les choses.
Voilà,
c'est notre condition.
Nous qui nous considérons
des chrétiens.
Quand on pense
à l'évangélisation,
on pense à faire
exactement ces choses-là.
L'évangélisation
n'est jamais plus
que ce que ces hommes
ils ont fait.
Mais n'est jamais moins.
Qu'est-ce que je veux dire
avec ça ?
Aujourd'hui,
nous sommes très confortables
en ne pas faisant
des efforts
pour ramener les personnes
jusqu'à la présence
de Christ.
Des fois,
on fait beaucoup moins
que ça.
Ils ramènent les personnes
jusqu'à la présence
de Christ
et ils implorent
avec foi
pour que les Christ
lui guérisse.
Des fois,
on tombe toujours
dans l'activisme.
On essaie
d'évangéliser,
d'évangéliser.
On n'est pas en train
d'emplorer
à Dieu
pour les guérir.
On n'est pas en train
de prier.
Des fois,
on veut nous-mêmes
faire semblant
qu'ils se sont convertis.
On veut les baptiser
très vite.
On veut suggérer
qu'ils changent
leur comportement
avant qu'ils soient
capables
de voir les choses
clairement,
les choses spirituelles.
Ça veut dire,
des fois,
on veut faire plus.
Qu'est-ce que ces hommes
ont fait?
Ces hommes-là,
c'était très clair
pour eux
qu'il ne s'agissait pas
des moralités
ou des efforts au moins.
Tout ce qu'ils pouvaient faire,
c'était vraiment
de prendre cet homme-là
et de les mettre
dans la présence de Jésus
et d'attendre
que Jésus
prend ses hommes par la main.
Et jusqu'au moment
où Jésus
ne prend pas
cet homme par la main,
il ne s'arrête pas
de faire leur travail
d'évangélisation.
Vous comprenez déjà
ce qui dit
en train de nous.
De faire des efforts
pour que les personnes
se trouvent
dans la présence de Christ.
Et c'est à Dieu
de faire le travail.
Nous,
nous sommes appelés
à s'aimer.
Nous sommes appelés
à prier.
C'est ce qu'est Jésus
qui peut faire
les changements.
On ne peut pas
simuler les changements
ni stimuler les personnes
à changer de vie.
Aujourd'hui,
on est en train
d'exiger
des morts spirituelles
un comportement
que seulement
un chrétien
peut vivre.
Prêcher l'évangile.
Ça, c'est le début.
Et après,
les changements,
c'est naturel.
Donc,
le troisième point,
c'est
pour être guéri
de la césité
spirituelle,
il faut permettre
aux médicins
d'évaluer
constamment
notre vision spirituelle.
Moi,
je pense que ça,
c'est le plus grand challenge
pour les chrétiens.
C'est énorme.
Et ça,
c'est depuis
le Nouveau Testament.
On passe très vite
de la grâce
de Dieu
qui nous a libertés
à l'orgueil
de notre comportement,
de notre performance.
Cet homme-là,
il était très honnête
avec le Christ.
Christ,
il a fait une invitation
à cet homme-là.
Est-ce que tu vois bien ?
La tentation
pour nous tous
est claire.
Je ne voyais rien
et aujourd'hui,
je vois des hommes
comme des arbres.
Moi,
je vois clair.
La seule chose
qui peut nous empêcher
de grandir
et de voir à Dieu
très clairement,
c'est dépenser
de nous-mêmes
plus eux
ce qu'on devrait penser.
La chose
qui empêche
le plus
notre croissance
spirituelle,
c'est le confort
avec une bonne situation.
Moi,
je n'aime pas,
aujourd'hui,
il y a une phrase
qui court partout
dans des églises
aujourd'hui,
des églises
très contemporaines
qui vont dire
« Le bon,
il est ennemi
de mieux. »
Ils utilisent
cette phrase-là
pour se dire
« Voilà que ta condition
physique,
matérielle,
elle est bonne aujourd'hui,
mais ce que Dieu
a pour toi,
c'est de la richesse,
c'est un mariage parfait.
Et donc,
ils sont toujours
très concentrés
avec les paramètres
des vies
qu'on peut voir
ici-bas
et maintenant.
Mais c'est clair
qu'il est bon,
il est ennemi
de mieux
quand on considère
notre capacité
de voir les crises
très clairement.
Et voilà
que les personnes,
elles considèrent
aujourd'hui,
il faut faire
très très attention
à ça,
qu'elles regardent
déjà les crises
très suffisamment.
Elles sont très confortables.
Et ça,
ça a des implications
partout.
On a commencé
en train de prier
pour la Pentecôte,
ça veut dire
la visitation
de Saint-Esprit.
Aujourd'hui,
on voit
que dans le milieu
charismatique,
des fois,
on voit beaucoup
d'exagération.
On voit des personnes
qui sont plutôt
centrées
dans les conséquences
d'un baptême
avec le Saint-Esprit.
Mais quoi dire
des églises
traditionnelles
qui,
quand elles voient
les exagérations,
veulent nier
complètement
la puissance
de Saint-Esprit
dans une église.
Nous sommes toujours
en train
de nous priver
des richesses
spirituelles
quand on pense
que c'est déjà
suffisant
tout ce qu'on est
en train de voir.
Et on reste
très limité
dans notre vie
et notre parcours
spirituel.
Il faut faire attention
à cet homme.
Il était honnête
avec les Christs
et c'est pour ça
qu'il a reçu
une nouvelle touche.
C'est pour ça
qu'il était capable
de voir encore plus.
Imaginez,
il n'y a aucune chose
qui puisse être pire
pour nous
devant Dieu.
Car devant les hommes,
on peut faire semblant.
Mais imaginez,
devant Dieu,
nous sommes en train
de dire,
Jésus,
il nous visite,
il nous dit,
voilà que je vois
que tu ne vois pas
encore très bien.
Est-ce que tu vois
très bien?
Nous disons,
non, non,
je vois déjà très bien.
on empêche,
dans le sens,
Jésus un peu
de rentrer encore plus
dans nos vies
et d'accomplir
les nettoyages
qu'il veut faire
pour qu'on puisse
les voir plus clairement.
Il faut faire attention
à ça.
Lui,
il voit clairement,
il connaît
notre condition.
Il est là en train
de vous inviter
aujourd'hui à réfléchir.
Je pense que l'Évangile,
le chapitre 8
démarre que nous sommes
en train d'étudier
dans cette Église.
Moi, il n'y a pas
besoin que je sois
un prophète pour dire ça.
Je suis en train
de voir une chose
se passer.
Je suis sûr
que la providence
de Dieu
nous apporte
un moment de réflexion.
Des fois,
j'ai la sensation
que nous pensons
beaucoup plus
de nous-mêmes
que l'on devrait.
Ça veut dire
qu'on pense
qu'on connaît Dieu
déjà d'une manière
parfaite,
complète.
Et voilà que Jésus
est en train
de nous inviter
à réfléchir.
Est-ce que nous sommes
disposés à lui permettre
de changer encore
notre vision ?
Pour qu'on puisse,
au lieu de voir
des hommes comme des arbres,
voir les choses
distinctement.
Amen.
Et donc,
le dernier point,
on permet à lui
de faire cette évaluation
on reçoit
son invitation,
avec transparence
on évalue
notre cœur,
et voilà,
si on répond
positivement à ça,
le quatrième point,
c'est pour être guéri,
ça c'est le dernier point,
pour être guéri
de la cécité spirituelle,
il faut regarder
constamment
et fixément
et exclusivement
les Christs.
C'est très intéressant.
Jésus demande
à cet homme,
est-ce que tu vas bien ?
Il dit,
je vois encore
les hommes
comme des arbres.
Je peux comprendre
son anxiété
pour voir les choses.
Peut-être
il était en train
d'écouter
de plusieurs personnes
ou peut-être
il était,
je ne sais pas,
on ne sait pas
s'il était aveugle
de naissance
mais il pourrait
avoir un rappel.
Et pour lui,
peut-être,
les choses qu'il voulait voir,
c'était le paysage,
la beauté,
les choses qui nous donnent
du plaisir dans la vision.
Donc,
Jésus lui donne
la première touche,
il regarde
l'environnement.
Et la douzième fois,
Jésus lui met
de nouveau les mains
sur ses yeux,
c'est-à-dire,
il est comme ça,
il touche ses yeux,
c'est une vision frontale,
et quand l'aveugle
regarda fixément,
il fut guéri
et vit tout distinctement.
Il était en train
de regarder quoi fixément ?
de regarder fixément
avec Christ.
Imaginez-vous,
nous étions en train
de considérer
au début du message
la possibilité
de voir
des choses belles.
Et on a dépassé
ces niveaux
et la possibilité
de voir
Dieu lui-même.
Et voilà que cet homme-là,
il sort d'un aveuglement
spirituel
pour voir par la première fois
avec perfection
la face
de Dieu lui-même.
C'est ça,
Dieu nous invite
à vouloir voir.
Est-ce que vous voulez
voir vraiment
la face de Christ ?
Ce texte,
il a une connotation
très personnelle pour moi.
Quand j'ai eu 14 ans,
je suis allé
dans une église.
C'était là
mon première rencontre
avec Dieu.
Et quelque chose
s'est passé dans mon cœur,
quelque chose
de très fort
et très spirituel.
Quand j'ai sorti de là,
c'était vraiment
quelque chose
énorme.
Donc moi,
j'étais en surfers,
je suis allé à la plage
et c'était comme si
toutes les choses
brillaient.
Mais vraiment,
c'était une impression,
une touche
de surnaturel
dans ma vie
et j'ai voyé
les choses très claires.
Ensuite,
j'ai fait une prière
auquel je n'ai répond
le plus de tout.
Mais j'ai dit à Dieu,
je sens
qu'il y aura
des implications
pour des changements
des vies en moi.
J'ai eu
la compréhension
que ces schémas-là,
c'est les schémas
de la vérité.
Ça fait déjà
un changement
avec moi,
mais je ne peux pas
me voir
en vivant
comme les chrétiens
qui vivent.
Ça veut dire
de laisser
tout derrière moi,
toutes ces habitudes-là
que je sais
que c'était pécheresse.
Et j'ai prévu
en disant
que tu puisses
enlever ces choses
doucement de moi.
et donc,
je passe
entre 5 et 7 ans
un peu éloigné
des schémas de Dieu.
Je n'ai trouvé
pas ma place
entre les amis
chrétiens.
Et je pense aussi
qu'à mon âge,
pas beaucoup
des adolescents
qui ont été élevés
dans l'église
étaient vraiment
déjà chrétiens.
Et c'est pour ça
qu'il y avait
un guet
entre nos relations.
Mais,
après,
j'ai eu
une visitation
de Saint-Esprit
dans une église
quand j'ai eu
19 ans.
et c'était
une expérience
tellement énorme
et incroyable
avec le Saint-Esprit
que j'ai mis
en question
ma première expérience.
C'est difficile
pour moi
de me dire
voilà,
ma conviction
c'était ces jours-là
ou c'était ces jours-là.
Ce que je sais,
c'est que
ça m'a donné
une capacité
de regarder
les choses spirituelles
de manière incroyable.
Donc,
cette deuxième touche
elle peut représenter
plusieurs choses
dans nos vies spirituelles.
Ça peut représenter
juste les progrès
d'où
qu'une fois
que nous sommes nés
à nouveau
il faut travailler
pour nettoyer nos cœurs
et ça se passe
progressivement
pour certains
mais ça peut sembler aussi
à cette promesse
que Jésus nous donne
dans le Nouveau Testament
d'une visitation.
Si vous
qui êtes mauvais
vous savez
donner des bonnes choses
à vos enfants
combien plus
Dieu ne nous donnera
pas
son Saint-Esprit
à ceux
qui les demandent.
Et donc,
il faut qu'on puisse
être là
en train de demander
à Dieu
de nous donner
une nouvelle touche
et qu'on puisse
regarder
les ministères
je voulais
vraiment finir par là
mais
les ministères
du Saint-Esprit
c'est quoi
les ministères
du Saint-Esprit ?
Si on regarde
la Pentecôte
pourquoi ils ont reçu
des signes miraculeux ?
Pour que les messages
sur l'écrit
soient plus clairs
et plus compréhensifs.
Les ministères
du Saint-Esprit
c'est toujours
de pointer vers l'écrit.
ça veut dire
il faut qu'on soit
en train
de regarder
fixément
et exclusivement
la face
de Christ
et plus tôt
et plus tard
on sera encore
plus guéri
et on pourra
voir les choses
et ça aussi
une connotation
pour la voir.
1 Corinthiens
13-12
nous dit
aujourd'hui
certes
nous ne voyons
que d'une manière
indirecte
comme dans un miroir
un miroir ancien
un miroir qui n'était pas
clair
alors
nous verrons
directement
dans les temps présents
je connais
de manière partielle
mais alors
je connaîtrai
comme Dieu
mais comme
un jour
on va joindre
les anges
pour voir
la présence
de Dieu
d'une façon
directe
et quel est
le résultat ?
Il faut guérir
parfaitement
et il voit
toutes les choses
distinctement
ça veut dire
comme C.S.L.
il disait
je crois
que dans le christianisme
pardon
je crois
dans le christianisme
comme je crois
que le soleil
est né
non seulement
par ce que je vois
mais parce que
par lui
je vois
tout le reste
c'est énorme
quand on passe
par un moment
de guérison
de notre abeux
de l'homme
le Christ
il devient
vraiment très clair
mais même
la vie
n'a pas
plus de sens
toutes les choses
qu'on regarde
sont plus
compréhensibles
pour nous
je voulais
vous inviter
à prier
à ces moments
là
un dernier signe
de sa guérison
spirituelle
c'est le fait
qu'il obéisse
à Jésus
il n'y rentre
plus dans le village
donc ça
a des implications
très claires
Jésus
il avait déjà
donné un jugement
envers les pharisiens
et la génération
corrompue
en disant
vous n'allez plus
voir des miracles
et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il fait
ces miracles
hors du village
et il demande
à cet homme
de ne pas rentrer
et cet homme
il obéisse
à Jésus
pour pouvoir digérer
ces choses
là
mais en fait
je voulais vous inviter
à prier
à ces moments
là
je vous invite
à vous lever
à ces moments
là
je voulais m'adresser
à deux situations
différentes
que vous pouvez
être en train
de vivre
à ces moments
en première
c'est la possibilité
que tu n'as jamais
vu le Christ
tu n'as jamais
reçu la touche
de Christ
et voilà
l'appel des dieux
nous sommes là
aujourd'hui
à travers cette prédication
de faire le travail
de ces hommes
qui ont apporté
l'aveugle
jusqu'à la présence
des dieux
de Christ
c'était la situation
pour nous tous
qui sommes chrétiens
aujourd'hui
donc on va prier
on va implorer
à Dieu
qu'il puisse
te permettre
de vivre
avec la vérité
la face de Christ
et pour le deuxième groupe
je voulais
vous inviter
à faire une évaluation
de votre condition
spirituelle
je voulais vous inviter
à dire à Jésus
moi
je vois beaucoup
des choses
déjà
je veux voir
plus clair
à pleine force
puis on somme
à la fin
de la mort
qui est
à la fin
de la mort